All right, good morning and welcome to
Bedichek Middle School for our
superintendent talk over consolidation
and closure tap
plans. And so,
I just want to thank you for being here
this morning and to be part of this
conversation and to have a space to
ask questions and understand more about
what's happening to our Bedichek
community here.
And just, you know, thank you for being
here for this piece. And without further
ado, I'm going to go ahead and introduce
our superintendent, Superintendent
Segura, is going to come up here and
go ahead and get us started.
Oh, sorry. We're going to do it this
way.
>> Good morning, everyone. We'll get to the
superintendent shortly, but I'll just
get us going in terms of the agenda and
what to expect from our time together.
My name is Ali Giller Ducey. I'm the
senior executive director of
communications and community engagement.
So, we're going to go over some meeting
norms and the purpose of this meeting.
I'll do introductions of some of the
folks that are here to help answer
questions alongside the superintendent.
And then we're going to give an overview
of the proposed changes specific to this
campus, as well as if you
recall on Friday, we released a revised
version of the draft plan. So, we're
going to talk about what changed from
the original draft to this next version
that we're working on now. And then
y'all have submitted questions, many of
you, through our comment card. And so,
we pulled those questions, looked at
which ones came up the most often, and
we have those prepared so that we can go
over there those. And then if you have
any follow-ups to that, you're welcome
to can be a conversation. And then there
should be plenty of time for just open
questions after that. And then we'll
talk about next steps.
So, for our meeting norms, we're here to
build a future together. We want to
acknowledge the challenges of the
current situation while focusing on
ideas and solutions that make our
district stronger, more equitable, and
sustainable for years to come. Um, we
want to honor time, so when we do get to
questions, we're going to ask that to
the extent possible, speakers try to
limit their comments to about a minute.
Um, that allows there to be enough space
for everyone to share. Um, we want to
honor each other, so speak to, not at
one another. Um, we want to be
respectful. Um, avoid interrupting. Um,
I will call on people, and if there's a
follow-up, we can pop around a little,
but we want to try to honor the order
that we're called on.
Um, honor the process, so we want to try
to stay on the agenda. Honor intent and
impact, so we may disagree on ideas, but
we hope that we can all agree and assume
that everyone's here for the same
reason, which is um, to have strong,
equitable schools for all of our
students. Um, we want to honor space and
voice, so if you do speak once, we're
going to ask that we get to others who
haven't spoken yet before we get around
to the same person again.
Um, we want to try to stay
solution-oriented, so um, we know that
there's a lot of probably concerns, but
if we can think about what it would take
to
to um, to solve for those concerns, that
really helps us cuz that's what our job
is going to be, whatever is voted on in
November is then to implement it
successfully. So, we're looking to you
to tell us what it would take. Um, and
lastly, um, we're here to embrace
transparency and empathy. We know these
conversations are difficult, but we are
here to be open, honest, transparent,
and as clear as possible. So, if that if
you ask a question and you feel like
maybe we didn't answer it, let us know,
you know, say that wasn't quite exactly
what I was asking. Um, we want to make
sure that you do get your questions
answered.
Um, and the purpose of today's meeting,
like I said, we want to respond to
questions submitted via the comment card
cuz those are things that came up again
and again. Um, we want to have a shared
understanding of what is proposed and on
the table right now, and then we as the
administration want to gain insight that
are going to inform potential
refinements to this plan um, before the
November 20 vote.
And so, with that, I will pass it over
to our superintendent. And because we
have this tree here, we're going to ask
that you stay on this side of it so the
camera can get you. We are, just so you
know, recording this meeting in English
and Spanish and it'll be posted to the
website within about 24 hours if you
want to share it out with anyone who
couldn't be here.
>> Thank you, Ally. Um
So stay to the left of it. Right here?
>> Yeah, just don't go too far that way.
>> Okay.
Um so appreciate all of you all coming
out this morning
uh and having a conversation around
uh the plan um
you know, kind of all the movement as it
pertains to Bedichek Middle School. And
so we want to create a space and a
dialogue with you.
Before we get into kind of that, you
know, Q&A, I do want to kind of have a
conversation around why this work and
why this work now.
One of the things that we've been
talking about um as a school district
between the board and the administration
for the better part of 2 years is that
um
we need to ensure that all of our
students have what they need to be
academically successful.
But also recognize that there are many
other things required to become
academically successful than just what
pours into the classroom.
Right? We need to make sure we have
services. We need to make sure that we
have programming. We need to make sure
we have alignment.
And the reality is that in Austin ISD
there are very strong neighborhood
schools, but there are also schools
where families choose to leave that
neighborhood and go to a different area.
And when you think about where we are,
uh there are lots of pressures that we
have as we move down this path.
The first is that we don't have funding.
Y'all know that.
State of Texas, federal government, the
challenges we've had have made it
really, really, really hard
to ensure that we have those resources
to deploy where they need to, right?
Focusing on the students who've been
historically
Secondly, we have to recognize that the
accountability system is changing.
It It just is.
And if we're not responsive to it, uh we
could very much introduce risk that
could take local control out of Austin
ISD.
Right? And your trustees
are here to provide that clear direction
for the school district. And we need to
ensure that that continues.
The other thing I would say is, you
know, over the last many years you've
seen enrollment in Austin ISD decline.
A lot of it is is not um There are
things that
contributed to that that are outside of
our control.
The city has changed. We've been here
for 144 years as a school district, and
the city has evolved around us. And our
schools are in certain locations, and
students move, and there's adjustments,
and and the cost of living has continued
to increase. And so, all these things
have put a tremendous pressure within
our school system.
And so, if we want to get to where we
have strong neighborhood schools, with
all of these pressures that we're having
to
manage,
then we have to do something
comprehensive.
And so, this plan includes several
elements. I'm going to name them.
There's really five.
The first is that we were endeavoring to
ensure that we had aligned feeder
patterns when this was all said and
done.
Well, what is an aligned feeder pattern?
An aligned feeder pattern is where you
have,
you know, one elementary school go to no
more than two middle schools, and then
one middle school go to no more than two
high schools.
You can imagine where that occurs. Right
now, we have that in Austin,
but it's not in East Austin. It's not in
North Central Austin.
Right? We have schools We have middle
schools that go to
three, four, and five high schools.
And so, think about the complexity of
and the lack of alignment or how
families and communities get broken up
when they move through our education
system. So I really wanted to make sure
that our boundaries in our realignment
our work here align those feeder
patterns.
Two,
we really wanted to address
challenges around our transfer process.
Whether it was a policy or a standard
operating procedure, there are policies
in place that have led to outcomes
that were not intended.
And so we have to be honest about it. We
have to understand if we need to make
adjustments, you know, what those
adjustments look like so that moving
forward we have the ability to manage
those transfers in a way that doesn't
create imbalance in our system. And so
you'll see that in the plan as well.
Three,
we have too many seats in Austin ISD.
Even with adjustments in capacity and
accounting for all of our student needs,
we still have over 20,000
empty seats.
Right? To put that in context, that's
3,000 more than the Moody Center.
Right? Take the entire Moody Center then
add 3,000 on top of that. That's how
many seats we have open
in Austin ISD.
And so what happens is when you have
that many empty seats,
it becomes very, very costly because of
how we support our school system.
And the only way to reduce our cost is
to consolidate.
Right?
In 1996,
we had about 73,000 students.
And we had about 96 campuses.
Now in 2025,
you have 70,000 students, but you have
112 116 campuses, I'm sorry.
And so you can really see that we grew
in certain areas and we contracted in
certain areas and unless we align
everything, we're not going to be able
to provide what we need to our students
to ensure success.
The other thing that I want to talk
about, the accountability system.
Right, we have to be really honest about
our schools and acknowledge that we as a
school district
have not ensured that our students and
our schools get what they need to be
academically successful.
This is not our students' fault. It's
not our families' fault.
It is just a series of decisions or
indecisions the last many, many years
like compressed with the pressure from
the state
that has arrived to where in this plan
we have to be responsive to those
risks. And those are risks.
When you have
you know, unacceptable accountability
ratings for consecutive years and given
how many we have because of how big we
are,
if we don't manage those correctly and
if we don't support those students and
ensure that we get there,
it could be very challenging for us to
ensure local control.
And so, uh, the last thing I'll say is
we wanted to also ensure that we aligned
programs in Austin ISD. There are
programs that have been built
and they have been supported, but over
time because of changing demographics,
the
student who was the focus or the the
primary student group who was founded to
support that program has shifted.
And we talk a lot about our emergent
bilingual students and the fact that we
have wall-to-wall dual language programs
where the student population, number of
students who are emergent bilingual, who
are were meant to be the focus of that
program have continued to decline,
decline, decline, decline.
And that's because they don't live in
those areas anymore.
And so if we're going to stabilize those
programs, we need to move them and
provide access.
So, um,
I'll I don't know what happened, but
I'll kind of go over on this slide. So,
as y'all know in the plan, um, it does
contemplate
um, you can go to the next slide.
Uh, Bedichek Middle School closing
uh, and then uh, at a later date
reopening. We're going to talk about
what that looks like. Uh, your trustee,
the trustees uh, and I have been talking
about, you know, what that looks like.
We'll talk about timing. We'll talk
about what needs to occur between now
and then.
Once we go through the closure
we have to assign the turnaround plan,
the TAP
from Bedichek to another school.
And the way that that occurs is by which
school receives the majority of the
students.
And based on where Bedichek is
surrounded by middle schools, Covington
will receive the majority.
One of the things that we changed
between the first plan and this plan, or
I'd say one of the things we revised is
that Lively has been uh, taken off the
list as a receiving school.
And that's really a function of just
having too many splits and wanting to
align the feeders in this area.
Um, not just, you know, the balance of
students. It was really trying to figure
out where we could limit disruption. So,
we we did some work and made sure that
we could um,
have fewer schools receiving.
The other thing I wanted to say is
um,
on the next slide, if you go to the real
quick to the
Yeah, so uh, we are looking at um,
I want to be really clear. I recognize
how important Bedichek Middle School is
to South Austin. Just to be honest, I
grew up in South Austin. I know this
area incredibly well. This is an
important important campus for Austin
ISD.
But the reality is I have to make
changes if we're going to evolve as a
school district.
But the board and I have talked about,
you know, re-envisioning what Bedichek
could be
you know, after we get through these
series of decisions and transitions.
And so, one of the things that I want to
be really clear about is I cannot turn
around and start a school next year.
Right? The Texas Education Agency has to
approve what that school will be.
So, there's time, there's planning,
there's feedback from the community,
there's alignment with need.
And so, one of the things that we're
working through right now is how to put
enough definition in the plan
so that you all can hold me accountable
to deliver, as well as our trustees,
but also recognize that
there may be things that are not in here
that come about by way of having
conversations with the community and
also having conversations with staff and
understanding our student needs.
So, we'll talk about that. It's kind of
a a challenging um place to be just
because you want to provide certainty,
but know that if we provide too much
certainty, it could ultimately be
challenging for us to uh be successful
because we haven't gone through that
process with you.
>> Matthias, real quick, I just want to let
you know it sounds like um some students
are planning on a demonstration, so they
may be making their way here soon. So,
we can maybe we can keep going, but I
think once they're nearby, we might want
to pause and see if they have any
questions or message that they want to
share with you.
>> Okay.
So,
>> And this is about the updated transfer
policy. You want to talk about
>> um
we've we we're making lots of changes in
our transfer um
uh
procedures and uh
and our approach. Uh one of the things I
want to be really clear cuz it wasn't
clear in the first plan is that if you
are a transfer student into Bedichek,
you will be automatically approved to
any one of the schools that you choose
to go to other three receiving schools.
So, if you transfer in from outside the
district, let's say you're from
Kyle and you come to Bedichek, and most
of your students, families, or friends
are going to Covington, we would
automatically approve that transfer.
Right? I do not want families
to be disrupted. This is already a big
enough disruption as it is. So, we're
making that commitment. If if the
students go to Paredes and your child
wants to go to Paredes and they're
transferring into Bedichek, we would
approve that as well.
So, I just want to be clear that is a
change that we've made. The other thing
that we've changed is that if you are a
rising sixth or ninth grader, or let's
say you're in fifth grade and the entire
time you thought you were going to go to
this middle school, or if you're in
eighth grade and the entire time you
thought you were going to this high
school, we're going to go ahead and
approve all of those transfers and not
have the boundary changes
control. All right, we we want to make
sure that we let communities know you've
been planning, you've been preparing
your student, we're going to go ahead
and approve that transfer and just make
that across the board. We've looked at
the numbers, we can do it.
Now, over time we'll have to kind of,
you know, we'll
get back to a balanced uh
transfer strategy and and and manage our
policies in a in a better way,
but I want to make sure those are two
very specific changes in this plan that
weren't shown or weren't clearly
identified on October 3rd release.
Yeah, Christine, do you want to walk
through this as far as the
settle on that side? This one only
controls this one.
>> Thank you. My name is Christine
Steenport. I'm the operations officer
for Austin ISD. So, I just kind of
wanted to take you through the boundary
map here.
You might have seen a small change just
like Superintendent Segura said earlier,
we had our version two come out on
Friday, October 31st. And so, we just
made a a little minor adjustment really
to help with those splits that
Superintendent Segura was talking about.
So, previously we had a portion here
that was to Lively, very very very small
portion. And so, when we did that it
cleaned up a split for Williams
Elementary School to not feed into
multiple middle schools. It also solved
for a Saint Elmo's split as well. So,
really that is just a change. So, you're
Oh, thank you. Sorry, I need to speak
up. Thank you.
I will do that. So, as you can see here,
I'll sit down on this side so that
speaker doesn't get to me.
So, this is the boundary for Bethelem
Middle School currently. And then this
is the new boundary drawn. So, if you
live in this area in blue, you would be
zoned to Peredes. If you live in this
area in green, then you would be zoned
to Covington. And then if you are in
this area in purple, you would be zoned
to Mendez Middle School. So, that is
that change from version
one where we had a little small split up
to Lively. And like I said, it changed
that to be able to
solve for some other splits as well and
to make sure we keep the students
together as much as we can.
Um, so that is the boundaries there.
Um, yeah.
Go to the next slide.
Thank you.
>> Um, and this is the last piece about the
turnaround plan. So, I think we've in
some of the meetings that we've had with
you all before about the turnarounds,
um, this is kind of just reiterating
some of what we shared before, but um,
in the instance where a school that has
required turnaround plan is being
reassigned to other schools, um, the
turnaround plan is going to follow where
the majority of students go. So, in this
instance, the majority of students are
being assigned to Covington. So, that
turnaround plan is going to follow them
to Covington. And so, that plan will
then become the plan of the the new um,
Covington Bethelem kind of combined
school community. So, once we have
approval on all of our plans, then we
can start beginning to work with those
school communities, um, to make sure
that the plan um, reflects kind of the
needs of the combined school community.
Um, there will be an appointment of
principals. So, for any schools that are
being consolidated, whether there's a
turnaround plan or not involved, um,
there is going to be a an appointment of
the principal. This is actually going to
be by our superintendent in December.
And that's, you know, as short quickly
after the vote as we can, we want to
make those decisions so that we can then
start providing certainty to staff,
right? Because the staff once we have
the principal, then they can start
working with our administration to start
selecting staff. Because the sooner we
can let staff know where they're going
to be, the less likely we are that
they're going to feel that anxiousness
and feel like they need to look for
options outside of Austin ISD because
that is not what we want. Um
so current if you have that turnaround
plan, there are requirements of staff um
to be able to stay and serve at the
campus. If you're a staff person who
doesn't meet those requirements, um then
there's going to be a kind of a second
layer of um hiring where we will do
hiring fairs where you can teachers and
staff can see which campuses have
availability. Um and then we're our our
effort will be to try to find a place
for those staff no later than April.
There'll be a couple rounds of that um
to make sure that anyone who wants to
stay with us is given several options.
Um
and then um the other thing about the
turnaround plans, part of what this
consolidation plan allows us to do is it
as we talked about, it's about freeing
up resources, having less resources
going toward aging buildings and more
resources going where we need them. So
each turnaround plan campus, which
Bedichek, Covington would be one, would
receive around $800,000 in extra funds
to be used as that principal and
leadership team um see fit. So that can
be for things like instructional
coaches, um content interventionists,
extra counselors, um however that they
think that they want to use those funds
to best support the goals in the
turnaround plan.
Okay. And that was the last of the
information that we had to present to
y'all. Um and so we now have the comment
card questions that we prepared.
>> You want to start off with just any
questions here before we go to public
comment?
>> what you like to do, sure.
>> Yeah, I think there's probably a couple
questions. So, what we did is we we we
have gotten lots of comments and so
we've kind of prompted some questions
based on those comments, but if there
are questions here, you know, we're
happy to start and then kind of just go
back and forth or you know, this is this
is your time to get your questions
answered for you know, us to have a
conversation and support better check as
you move forward.
Yes, ma'am.
>> I'm going to have you come use the mic
so that the video catches it.
This way.
All right.
Hi, my name is Renee Geneva Rainey Co. I
am the president of the PTA of St. Elmo
Elementary.
Sorry for the nerves in my voice.
So, we are a feeder school into this. We
are split between
Mendez,
Covington, et al.
I appreciate appreciate Sorry, now I'm
going to have to read. I appreciate all
the work that's gone into redrawing
these boundaries and I understand it's
complicated, but the proposed changes,
which we just saw in the map, it
segments this super little part of St.
Elmo and it throws it across the
highway,
across I-35. Those are the boundaries
that AISD did say they would respect
with major arteries and now they are
pushing our kids across those
boundaries. I don't even know why. It's
such a little section. We were slated
with the last plan
proposed to Covington
and that makes more sense.
On top of that,
uh
Mendez is a charter one school
by Third Future. Is that correct?
>> Currently, yes.
>> Okay, so they are not having AISD hired
teachers, correct?
>> Currently, yes.
>> Okay.
Thank you.
My tax dollars
>> Kids don't go there and they
Yeah, your tax dollars
They're going to AISD. Why are we
putting them into a charter school?
So, thank you. Thank you for being here.
Thank you.
>> So,
So, um, yeah, I don't want you to leave
Austin ISD. I What I Hey, so
So,
everything that um, she said is is
accurate. One of the things I'll tell
you is this plan is forward-facing,
right? 26, 27, and beyond. So, yes,
there has been historically a an
agreement with Third Future to operate
Mendez. Um, we're going through that
conversation now. I am hyper aware that
ALC is located there. I'm also probably
I'm not certain if you all have heard,
but we've had We're having
conversations. It was based on some
ideas in our board work session that
looks at potential moves,
uh, in order to to kind of create the
space at Mendez to to revert back. You
know, it's going to be an Austin ISD
school.
Uh, you know, that they were Third
Future was never intended to be
uh, partner in perpetuity, right? They
They were They were brought in to to do
work
and they've accomplished that work. Um,
we will take it back. The question
becomes is what does that transition
look like? How do we ensure that all of
our students are welcomed and that it is
truly an Austin ISD school, but also
that we staff it correctly,
uh, and ensure that, you know, we don't
um, kind of introduce more risk. It When
I'm being that it's to start up a
school, uh,
it it takes resources, it takes
planning. Um, so, we're working through
that now. So, everything that you said
is accurate. We are working through it.
I am aware, um, and it is one of those
things that if you're
You may have heard, uh, and based on the
last work session, we are working
through right now. That is That is an
area of concern for me as well.
>> I also want to add uh, Superintendent
Segarra that currently if students are
assigned to Mendez, the district
automatically approves their transfer. I
believe it's I might be wrong, but I
believe it's Paredes, Bethe Check, or
Lively that families have the option to
go to. So, historically as a district,
if there has been a charter in place,
we've given families options if that
doesn't feel like the right fit for
them.
I'm going to go ahead and go to the
first comment card and we can kind of go
back and forth. So, the first one
How can Austin ISD ensure this closure
is not disproportionately punishing
Bethe Check's student population, which
is almost exclusively underserved
segment of the district? This is from
Andrea H.
Yeah, so um
whenever we look at impact of students,
we always think about which students
have been historically underserved.
Um what are we going to do to ensure
that uh they are supported through any
transition? They are They are closest to
this work.
And
what I'll say is it really comes down to
us being very clear and very transparent
about what is coming and then spend the
energy and resources and planning. Like
that's that what is what has to happen.
If we wait till the spring semester or
if we wait later and all of a sudden a
change happens and we have like two or
three months to prepare, that is going
to adversely impact our students who
have been historically underserved to a
greater degree. The way that you can get
in front of that is you take the time to
thoughtfully plan. What supports will
they need? What wrap-around services
will they need? You know, how do we work
with families to communicate effectively
in support our students wherever they
are?
So So, that is really the the I think
the main point of the our response to
this question is
because of who we are as a school
district, there are going to be impacts
to students who have been historically
underserved. And we have to get in front
of it and the way that you do that is
with thoughtful planning, with student
voice, with community voice, and then
hold me accountable on executing those
plans and providing those supports.
Go to
Our students showed up.
>> Good morning.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> SO, DID Y'ALL HAVE A MESSAGE THAT YOU
WANTED to share? Is there or did you
have a question for the superintendent?
Is someone going to represent y'all?
Are you just here to listen for now? And
maybe if you if you think of a question,
we'll keep going and if you think of a
question, you can raise your hand.
You have a paper in your hand. Is that
something you prepared?
No, okay.
>> Well, thank y'all for for for coming. Uh
this is important. You know, if you It's
important that I hear
you know, what ideas, what concerns, um
you know, what is going through your
mind. You know, you all are the reason
that we exist. Like, we're here to
support students.
That's it. That's the only reason AISD
exists.
And so, I know that it's it's hard right
now. I know there's a lot of of things
that are going through your mind, but
please, please, please let us know how
we can support you. This is hard. Um and
it's okay to have different types of
feelings, but you got to let us know
what's in your mind so that we can
support you better.
Um so, please, please, if you have
anything, just share with us.
Um if you have a question, I can stay
around later, we can talk.
>> If you could come over here. You know,
Matthias, if you'll stand over here, I
think the camera can get you on this
side. Yeah.
You can do it. You're doing all right.
>> Why are we shutting the school down?
Like
>> So, um
I'm having to
to do it because
there are
four really big things that are
happening right now that impact
Bedichek.
One is that there aren't enough students
that live in South Austin
between Covington, Paredes, Lively,
Bedichek.
And so, whenever we think about what it
takes to to support all of our students,
whenever we have small schools, it
becomes really I'm going to use a word
inefficient, meaning that it's it's
costly.
And what we know is that as enrollment
has declined, meaning there's fewer and
fewer students, because it's kind of
expensive to live here,
we have to make a decision, or else I
cannot ensure that each of you get what
you need to be successful. You need
teachers, right? You got to have your
teachers.
We got to make sure we have programs. We
got to make sure that after school
activities, all those things require
resources, you know,
money and and other things. And unless I
can find ways to operate uh in a way
that's less costly, I can't make sure
that you have what you need
throughout your career in Austin ISD.
So, it's it's tough. Um it it's That is
That is why we're having to make this
decision. That is That is why.
Thank you. What's your name?
>> Uh Rosabella.
>> Rosabella, what grade are you in?
>> Huh?
>> What grade are you in?
>> Eighth grade.
>> Oh, great job.
Hey, where are you going to go next
year, Rosabella?
Ooh, I love Crockett. Crockett's
amazing. That's awesome.
Great job.
Pregunta? You got any questions?
>> What's going to happen to our GT classes
and our Einstein classes, like geometry?
>> So, the the question was what happens to
GT Einstein um
So, our my job is to make sure that we
have programming to support you.
Right? And you have incredible programs
at Bedichek. And as we move through the
transition process, we're going to
determine, okay, what do each of you
need,
you know, at these other schools, and
then ensure that we have the resources,
the people, the programs in place to be
there at those schools and welcome you.
Right now, I will be honest, some
schools have different programs and
other schools have different programs,
but it's always based on student need.
So, if the students here, based on what
you've taken and where you want to go,
have these um uh
kind of desires or you want to see these
opportunities at your school, we, as a
school district, make that decision.
Programs can move,
right? Programs move all the time. I
just need to make sure they're there for
you and welcoming you when you go to
that program. So, they'll continue on
with you.
Great great question. What grade are you
in? Are y'all eighth graders?
No, seventh?
Sixth?
Where are you going next year?
Akins? Let's go. Awesome. Thank you.
Great question.
Yeah.
>> So, we're doing Q&A with the
superintendent. We've had two students
who had questions. I know we had some
new students come in. Um this is your
opportunity if you want to share your
thoughts or if you have any questions
for the superintendent.
And we can always come back to the
students if we have maybe someone in um
here. Okay, we'll go here and then if
students think of questions, um raise
your hand and we'll come to you.
>> Hello, my name is Stephanie Mata. I have
um a son in seventh grade and in eighth
grade. My question is,
why would you ren- ren- ren- renovate
the front office and the security if we
were going to if you guys had in mind to
close down?
>> Yeah.
So,
when we started planning the renovation,
That was in 2021-22,
right? Cuz it was funded with the 2022
bond program.
If there are staff and there are
students in our buildings, we're going
to support and make those investments.
But in '21 and '22, if you would have
told me that the state is not going to
give school districts funding,
right, as part of the 88th Legislature,
and if you would have told me that even
2 years later they would do it only to a
small degree,
um I wouldn't have believed you. Right?
That cuz of how many school districts
are struggling and how
how hard it is for our school districts
to keep up.
And so we did not know that we would be
here at when we started that project.
But I also want to communicate that if
the school, right, based on, you know,
our plans to the board gets approved,
you know, those dollars, you know,
ultimately will serve a campus again
here at Bettecher. So it won't won't be
wasted. Um I never want anybody to think
it's wasted. It's important that we
secure our buildings, that our students
feel safe, that our staff feel safe. As
soon as we know that something is
changing, then we will make adjustments
and we're doing that. But at the time
that that project started, uh we didn't
know we would be here. And then I would
say two, it's important no matter what
happens, that our students feel safe,
they are safe, and we, you know, invest
when we need to. That's why.
>> Did you have a follow-up?
One second. Matthias. We're going to
have you walk around this side so that I
think we got you a little more length on
the mic. One other quick announcement
before um you finish your question. Um
so if you are recording, um not every
student here has necessarily a media
release for their image to be um posted
online. We've talked to the media to
make sure, but we just want to let
everyone know here. Um if you're
capturing students, please um don't post
those unless you've verified with the
staff that they have that media release.
>> Another question. What's going to happen
to the um sped teachers?
>> Yeah.
So, I want to
I I need our students and our families
and our staff to know
at no point at at
at no point along this process
uh did I ever say anything other than if
our educators and our staff want to be
in Austin ISD, they will have a home,
period. So, what'll happen is um Ali
spoke to this, but I'll be clear
I'll clearer, sorry.
Um we're going to go through a hiring
process,
right? And it'll be based on the plan of
that campus. Covington will have a
different staffing plan than Paredes,
right? And it's a function of just where
they are in their academic journey. That
that's really it. But my intention is
that our students, our incredible
students, see familiar faces. That they
have welcoming, you know, leaders in
their schools whenever this transition
occurs. So, as these schools hire more
staff, my directive is to start with the
staff that were already at the campus,
right? That's what needs to be addressed
first. When it comes to um uh
our special education educators or other
staff, those are not placed by student
enrollment. That's placed on student
need. So, if there's a student that has
a need at Bedichek and they're going to
Paredes and that school maybe doesn't
have that unit or maybe has doesn't have
those supports, Dr. Cherry Lee, who's
the assistant superintendent of special
education, will evaluate and then place
the person or add the resource over
there because this happens all the time
where we have students who have
different needs move through our
organization and then we meet their need
at their home campus as best we can. So,
no special education staff, in fact, we
we we do not want anybody to leave. We
want no one we want no one to leave.
Um but when it comes to the uh special
education staff, that's how it will work
with placement. It won't just be based
on uh where the students go.
>> Okay.
Okay.
Real quick, um did you want to let Ms.
Dr. Lee just Do you have something as
well?
Oh.
Sure. I just I also one thing I thought
we might be able to clarify is because I
think there's been some confusion that,
you know, when you're closing
potentially 13 schools, you've probably
heard that number that that's going to
create 700 staff who are displaced,
right? Um so we're going to talk a
little bit about why it is that How is
it that these 700 are being freed up,
but but we're saying we're not going to
necessarily lose staff. So if you could
explain that, I think that might help a
little bit.
>> Yeah. So we are We have 70,000 students,
right? Almost 11,000 employees.
And every year every year we hire almost
700 teachers and educators and staff.
Right? So what that means is uh instead
of having to go outside
AISD to hire, what we're going to do is
hire those and place those who have been
with Austin ISD. That's the way that you
do this.
And so the total number of positions
will come down, but because of our size,
we have a real opportunity to protect
our educators and our staff who want to
stay with Austin ISD. And I want to be
really, really clear. We are taking
um our uh teachers' voice uh and our
staff voice into the process by way of a
survey. We know that, you know, some
educators who have lived in South Austin
or North Austin want to
have a different experience or maybe
teach at a different school. We're going
to take all of that into consideration
um and before we actually roll out final
uh staffing plans.
>> Thank you. Um students, do we have any
other questions over here?
>> You got a question back there, yeah?
>> Awesome. Come on up. You guys are being
so brave. Good job.
>> Great job.
>> Woah.
>> Uh what what are
What other options are available for
this school and what options are you
guys choosing to pursue?
Did you hear that?
>> No, I didn't hear it.
>> He said, "What other options are
available for this school and what other
options are we or what are we proposing
to do?" Did I get that right?
Awesome.
>> So, um
we looked at lots of options before we
got to this point. What's your name?
>> Lincoln.
Uh we looked at lots of options uh
before we got to this point. Uh one of
the things that I I want to reinforce is
that we have lots of empty seats in all
the middle schools in South Austin. And
that's just because people have moved
out of the area and there's just fewer
students that are sixth, seventh, and
eighth graders.
And so when we look at where our schools
are, you have kind of Bedichek in the
middle. You have Covington to the west.
You have Lively and Mendez to the north
and northeast and then Paredes to the
east. And so when you think about moving
students, uh it is really hard for one
school that's a kind of a a middle
school to move all together into another
middle school cuz they just won't fit.
Right? So, you have to look at how to,
you know, um move the students in a way
that creates balance in South Austin.
So, that's how we arrived at this
solution. I would tell you that it is
really a function of geography. Just
where Bedichek is.
I will tell you that before we got here,
I looked at I I I've reduced our our
expenses. I've reduced our total
expenses the last few years by over $100
million.
I've um reduced central office um staff.
I am doing everything possible before I
ever had to come and look at schools.
It's not what we wanted to do.
Um and so we arrived at this plan in
that way.
Uh and the the goal moving forward is to
go through this process and then here
restart Bedichek into a different
program based on what the community and
what our students need. So that would be
the plan moving forward. Is that
helpful?
Great question, Lincoln.
>> All right, I'm going to go over here.
>> you in, Lincoln?
>> Uh seventh.
>> Seventh, awesome.
>> Hello, my name is Shanda. I have a a
seventh grader or a sixth grader and a
seventh grader here. Um my daughter went
to Ann Richards and then she came to
Bedichek and so now she'll have to go to
another middle school next year.
Uh my son is in the special education
and with high anxiety I actually
probably 100% will pull him out of
school and home school him next year. So
he will not be back.
Um
it's going to be too hard to figure out
where to put them together and I won't
deal with, you know, the emotions on him
again. The math doesn't make sense to me
when you say you have empty seats
and you're not you're getting rid of all
the staff but you say you're having to
go out and hire all these teachers. So I
don't understand how you're having to go
out and hire these teachers but you have
all these empty seats that are coming
up.
>> Yeah, so so it's attrition rate, right?
So just over the course of a year you
have staff that just leave Austin ISD to
go to different school districts, maybe
they leave for personal reasons, many
retire. So so the attrition rate given
how big our our teacher
and staffing
kind of
group is just allows for us to hire in
that way.
>> Have you ever put out the accountability
for yourself to find out why they're
leaving your leadership under AISD?
>> So it's actually gone the opposite
direction. It's actually improved
significantly. So right now we're 97.4%
staffed. When I first came on board
we're about 84, 86% staffed.
>> the pay raise is why I came back to AISD
cuz they left our schools.
>> you asked a question and I'm trying to
give you a response, right? If if I
based on
attrition between title one and a title
one school. So when I first came on
board, when we came together, you would
have title one schools who had first
year teachers for a student 3 years in a
row, right? And so, every time a teacher
leaves and a new teacher comes in, you
know, getting them on board and making
sure they understand the climate and
culture, understand our students' lived
experiences, that takes time. And then
with the professional development to
ensure that they have the tools and the
skill set to support our students, that
just takes time. So, we were just losing
so many students so many teachers in our
title one schools. So, we've really
addressed that in a meaningful way. It
was 20% at one point, now it's less than
2 and 1/2 percent.
>> what I'm saying, why did they leave?
>> That was before I got I mean, I can
pandemic had a lot to do with it. Uh
fear-based culture and climate, uh not
having um principals um strong
principals in these positions. When I
first came on board, we hired over 20 I
think it was 26 principals that year.
You cannot have stability
>> have accountability being accountable
down the down the line, all the way
down.
>> Again, this was this was This was before
we all came together.
>> The next thing, the financial part of
it. When schools get paid, they get paid
because the students are sitting in the
seat, right? So, if a student's not in
the seat, they don't get paid for that
student that day.
>> Yeah, average daily attendance, yes.
>> Yeah. So, I I think that's where we need
to go to get the money. Because that
student is still there when they're
gone. That teacher still has to do the
work. The student still has to make it
up. The school shouldn't have to make a
budget based on how much they're going
to get from the government and then not
get that money from the government
because the students were gone.
Um so, that's where we as schools and
parents I think need to go fight for the
funding and make sure that we're getting
the actual money to for the students.
Yeah. The students are here, whether
they're gone or not.
>> Yeah. So, so you bring up a really good
um
point. I will tell you that in the last
2 years, I I I I will tell you that has
been a huge focus of ours is increasing
Y'all come to school, y'all. Our average
daily attendance. Average daily
attendance is it's what we have to use
to calculate funding. And so, let's say
that um
Matias, baby Matias, like comes to
school but is only comes for four days
out of a five-day work week. Well, that
that we get funded by how many days I'm
in the school, but just because I'm out
one day doesn't mean that our teacher is
out. We're still paying for our teacher
and our principal. And so in the last 2
years we've made a concerted effort to
increase average daily attendance.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh last year we finished the year over I
think 1.3% greater than the year before
and it seems like a small number, but
that is a huge number. 1.3%
>> Now, the way that we're going to
continue to tackle it is focusing on
chronic absenteeism. Uh but I'll tell
you that if you go another 1 and 1/2 or
2% you know, you're going to get 4 and
1/2 5 million dollars. You know, we're
talking about 70 80 million dollar like
budget deficit.
>> what I'm saying like they should give
that to you anyways. It shouldn't
matter. That's where I would love to
start the fight. You know what I mean?
Because that's beyond like you guys just
need that money period and you wouldn't
have to have this problem. Most of it
for
>> It it would be it would be very helpful
and there's been lots of advocates, your
board advocates, your community
advocates.
Uh we just know the state and the
legislature has not been responsive to
those
>> Do we take that to the capital?
>> I we've been taking it to the last 3
years.
Yeah.
I
I I I agree. It's just that it takes
lots of legislators and the governor to
to do that and based on what we've seen
it's not likely.
>> Thank you. We have another question
here.
>> Hi, good morning.
>> Good morning.
>> Um my question is I'm sorry, my English
is not a very good.
>> No, no, that's okay.
>> I have a child here.
Who was a better check and I have had
other children that were here before.
I was saying that there's really good
programs here in better check and now
that the I guess um
the change of zones based on the zip
code. Okay, can I say something?
What's going to happen to the programs
that which were her daughter's currently
in and she's going to be transferred or
sent to another school if those programs
are not available there. So that's her
concern about her her child going to
college and real programs.
>> Um
we create our programs based on our
students' needs.
And what programs are here were based on
better check students' needs.
And so as we move forward, it's really
really important that we transition and
we look at what programs are not not at
Covington that need to be at Covington.
What programs are not at Pereda's and
need to be at Pereda's because these
students are going to go there and we
need to make sure that they have
programs in place to support them.
Programs move. We, the school district,
support the building up of programs and
we help implement, right? Based on
leadership and based on community need
and student need. So, that's why the
transition plan is important so that I
have enough time to make sure that the
program is set up and ready to receive
your student and that they're successful
starting the 2026-2027 school year. But,
we will move up we will move programs
based on student need. That's that is
what we do.
Is that helpful?
Did I do it?
Yeah, we we will. I mean, that's we're
seeing this at high school also where
students who are going to one high
school who are now going to another high
school wanting to understand what
programs will be at that high school
that they are now being zoned to because
the school they thought they were going
to had these other offerings. And so, we
can make those adjustments. It's really
understanding our student needs,
developing a plan to implement the
program, and then doing it, like
executing the plan. But, that's what we
intend to do.
>> She expects she's hoping that the
changes you're talking about the
adjustments
>> Thank you. I will. I absolutely will.
So, the the question here was when do
you do it, right? Well, we're in this
in-between time, honestly, right now
where
uh
once a vote occurs,
um we have transition plans and
frameworks ready to to move forward
with, but we can't produce those until
we get student voice and community voice
into it. Because there may be things
that are at that campus that should
change. Or there are things that we need
to add, but I'm not going to sit here
and tell you what it needs to be. We
want to engage in a conversation and
say, "This is what our students need."
And then we execute that plan in the
spring semester, hire, make adjustments,
and then train, and then move forward in
the start of the new school year. So,
you would you would not have that now.
We're in this weird time where people
want to work and plan, but we don't have
a vote yet. And so, that's how it would
work. So, after November 20th, uh once
the vote occurs, we'll move forward,
we'll place the principals, we'll then
begin the the staffing plan, and then
come back and develop the academic
programs for each of the schools with
blended students. Because now we have
new students with different needs. Like
it should change. So, that's how it's
going to work, which is why the spring
semester is so important. That's why the
spring semester is so important. We
cannot make a decision in the spring
semester because we'll have zero time to
plan, and it'll ultimately hurt our
students starting the 2026-2027 school
year.
>> Superintendent Segura, I'm going to ask
you to come back around here because we
have a student question here.
>> Um, I have
>> name?
>> Uh, my name is Lillian. And
>> What grade are you in?
>> Um, I'm a seventh grader, but I I do
have a question. My question is uh, why
can't we as seventh graders finish the
year here
and for the sixth graders to go to the
other school?
>> So, that's a great question.
>> year or next or you mean finish eighth
grade here?
>> Finish eighth grade here.
>> Yeah.
So,
um
That's a great question cuz I'm going to
I
I want to respond, but I I want to
respond in a way that's very thoughtful.
Um
There are
the state of Texas, right? The There in
the Texas Education Agency,
they kind of determine um how they
believe schools are performing,
right? And they put these
letters, you know, in are so much
greater than any single assessment or
any single test on a single day.
But unfortunately, we are in a state
that has a different kind of approach.
And so, the reality that we're facing,
that I'm facing, that keeps that from
happening is that BETA Tech for the last
3 years didn't quite, even though
there's been great growth. I mean, we're
so close. Like academically, we're it's
so close, but from the state's
perspective, there's still three
consecutive years of not meeting
accountability. That's the word that we
used.
And so, if we do not make a change
and that fourth year comes,
then all of a sudden, um,
we, as the school district, um, may lose
our ability to support 70,000 students.
So, so here's an example.
Right? We're right now in a library.
Right? We love librarians in Austin ISD.
We believe in the love of reading, not
just reading to be great at a test,
right? I I hope that you love reading. I
love reading, though I don't get to read
that much.
And, um,
there are school districts right now
that don't have librarians.
Can you believe that? That that there
are schools districts in Texas right now
that don't have librarians.
We made that decision with our board and
the administration to say we value
librarians, we value nurses, we value
our curriculum. We We want to make sure
that we have control on what you learn
from every single year. Like, that's our
responsibility. If we do not address the
three,
um,
years of of not meeting accountability,
we could lose the control to make those
decisions for all of our students. So,
that there's kind of like an urgency
around it and a lot None of it has has
nothing to do with you all. You are
doing exactly what you should be doing.
It is really a function of me working
with the state to try to find this
balance. Um, but that's why we can't do
it because if you went one more year,
then it could be a fourth year and then
that kind of triggers other, um,
what we call them as interventions, but
bigger and bigger things the state could
do up until taking the district over.
Is that helpful?
>> Yeah.
>> That That was a great great question.
But whenever we can do that, we we like
to transition students in that way.
>> Maybe explain that that has happened to
other school districts.
>> Yeah, so, um,
right now,
um,
there are two school districts that are
currently,
um, being taken over or already taken
over by the state of Texas.
The first is Houston. You've heard of
Houston, right? Houston ISD. And then
recently
Fort Worth ISD. So Fort Worth is like
us. We're very similar in size. We're
about 70,000 students. And they recently
were notified that they um
would have what they call a board of
managers. And then the superintendent
would I mean
there's different things there. Um but
it happens. It can happen. And we cannot
avoid a hard decision because I want to
make sure that when you're in high
school and when your you know little
brother and sister or this generations
of students after you come like they are
getting education based on our values in
Austin. It needs to be our values. In
Austin we get to protect them. Even
though we got to make hard decisions
because at the end of the day like you
all should benefit from being in this
community and not being kind of informed
by the state. So that's how it's it's
it's happening. Great question. That's
all that's a great question.
>> Well like like us students have made a
new friends here and stuff like that.
But like if we all get separated, how's
that going to affect us?
>> Yeah, so that's that's where we have
teams come in and help.
And it's it's not going to be perfect
cuz there are going to be just based on
each family's
kind of current um kind of how each
family decides to to to approach this.
There will be splits. We are trying to
reduce the number of splits. Right? So
at one point there was like five schools
in four school. We really want to make
it fewer so there's bigger and bigger
groups. And then we're also let's say
that you don't maybe maybe you your
friends go to Paredes but you're
actually zoned to Covington.
What we would say is if you want to go
to Paredes, we'll approve you
automatically.
Like I want to make sure that our
students that each of you know like as
as hard as this is and it is hard and it
is disruptive and it I'm I really I'm
sorry for that.
I want to make sure that the transition
um
that we can do whatever we can to make
transition better. And it's never going
to be great. Uh but in that way we can
do it, you know, we can say go we can go
with your friends.
Um
but there's not a way for me to have
everybody go together because better
middle schools are just a little bit
bigger. In elementary schools we can do,
but not in middle schools.
>> Okay. We are getting close to a
transition period, so I'm going to ask
this student a question and then we have
one staff person that was hoping to get
in
>> Yes.
>> Um my question is
>> What's your name?
>> Ramiro.
>> Ramiro, what grade are you in?
>> Eighth grade.
>> Okay.
>> Do you have data that shows successful
rates splitting students up to other
schools?
>> Yeah, it There are There's
it really comes down to I've seen it
both ways. It can work well and it
cannot work well.
It really comes down to how much time
and energy and focus do we put on the
transition plan.
Right? So, if we just do it, you heard
me earlier talk about doing something in
the spring semester. Let's say I we did
this decision around spring break.
And then we got to hire, we got to plan
between spring break and summer.
We will not be successful. We won't.
Right? Because what we need to plan is
time. I need conversations with you and
your students. I mean your your your
your your peers and then our families
and then build out a plan that actually
works and test it and then hire to
ensure that it actually is done with
fidelity.
If we and and whenever it is done well,
those plans are thoughtful, they're
student-centered, and they're locally
built, like they're built with
community. Where I've seen it go poorly
is when it's a reaction. When we're
waiting late into the spring semester,
we make a decision, and we go and we
don't have time to plan. So, I've seen
it be
successful, but only if you plan and you
support our students and go through the
process. So, it's but
yes and no.
>> Okay.
>> We we control that though.
>> Yeah.
>> All right, we still have students and I
want to get to them for sure. Let's try
to do as quick of answers as we can to
get through.
>> Like I
>> So, if we did shut down, um,
what schools are we able to go to?
>> So, uh
Covington,
uh Paredes,
and Mendez. Those are the three schools
that are currently part of it. Now, the
majority of the students will go to
Covington, and then the second biggest
group will go to Paredes, and then a
smaller group will go to Mendez.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Oh, great question. Thank you. What was
your name?
>> Uh Akari.
>> I'm sorry?
>> Akari.
>> Akari. Awesome.
Thank you, Akari.
>> Uh my name is Walter and I'm in 7th
grade, but I'm just curious like how is
funding spread between schools? If it Is
it like spread evenly?
>> So, it is not spread So,
man, you got You all got some awesome
questions.
Great questions.
That was a great question. High five.
So, this is how funding works.
So, there's funding from this
We fund based on students and student
need. Let me give you an example.
If you have, um,
large numbers of students, then you're
going to have more teachers, right? Cuz
you got to have more teachers to support
our students.
We fund based on program.
If there are unique programs to a
campus, like let's say there's a dual
language program, or there's uh another
program, we would staff based on
language. So, so that's kind of more
allocations. Then we also staff on
unique programming. Let's say there is a
UIL related, um, kind of, uh,
program, whether it's fine arts or
athletics. If there are enough students
that have an interest in that,
especially in high school, then we would
also fund.
So, it's really based on student need.
Um, we where there are schools that have
had kind of just need more support, we
actually will provide more staff, um,
whether it's instructional coaches,
which are people that come help
teachers,
and just support teachers. We have
content interventionists which come help
our students just tackle some tough
problems from time to time. So, yes,
there's one baseline based on students
number of students, and then it goes to
student need, and then we make
adjustments there. So, it is not all
equal, but it is based on the needs of
the students. Yeah.
>> So, if funding is spread like that,
since the school shouldn't be done
because of our grades, right?
>> Mhm.
It's I would say that it's the number of
seats in all of South Austin,
right? And I think and what's put
pressure on it is the state's
accountability system, which is
kind of what they would say is is kind
of the grades, but not y'all's
performance. Like what's
>> I was just saying like what if we funded
like struggling schools like this a
little more?
>> So, we
So,
So, we we do
we do right now. The reality is
it's hard to take the next step because
I don't have more money.
Does that make sense? Like
if I had more funds available, I would
do more. But because of how many empty
seats we have across the entire
district,
I can't offer more without driving our
budget down, which creates additional
risk. So, yes, we do it already. We want
to do more, but I need to have money to
be able to do it.
>> And the plan that we're proposing
actually does put extra money into the
schools that are going to receive
students from Bedichek. So, there will
So, we're saving some money, but then
we're reinvesting it where the students
are going. Does that make sense?
>> What's your name?
>> Great job.
>> Walt, how's it? And you're awesome.
Seventh grade?
Awesome.
>> I'm going to come over this way, Matias,
to the to a staff person.
Hi, I'm Ms. Mendoza, Coach Mendoza.
Um
I wanted to say some positive things
real quick. I know that the students are
leaving and then their teachers are
leaving, too, but I feel like that there
have been some things that have been
said in this meeting that have
clarified, like geography and
accountability would be reasons why
Bedichek have been chosen to close,
although the messages out there have
been all over the place and coming from
standing in this library as a student
myself to a teacher,
um
I feel like I've heard a bunch of
information. I feel like I hear a lot of
things, but one thing that I don't hear,
um enough consistently consistently, is
all the positive things that we do even
academically. I understand that we have
some accountability issues according to
what the state currently rates our
schools,
um but to not publicly recognize the a
tremendous growth that we've had in
domain three, and even to say that we're
a campus who's going to go on with a
stigma of negative accountability,
um
it's a little crazy not to hear all the
positive things um about our campus,
especially when we have district people
asking us, "Well, how did you do that?
How did you do that?" And so, I just
wanted to commend the students for
coming in and orderly the teachers for
how they did it, but also to say that I
know that listening to things that are
out there in the media, um whether it's
from other media sources or AISD, that I
don't think we get enough credit for the
hard work that we've had to do under the
circumstances we had to do. So, I wanted
to put a bunch of positive things out
there for our campus.
>> Yeah, thanks for doing that.
You know, and and I think, um that's
what makes this so so hard is the
compression of the timelines because of
how '23, '24, '25 accountability came
out. Like, when I came here in the I
guess it would have been fall of 2024
um and then again in of 2025, right
right after the year.
You know, that's before 23
accountability came out. The lawsuits
were still, you know, stuck. We'd seen
the growth. Like, we were
really genuinely trying to build a plan
that could work at Bedichek and move us
in the direction we need to, stabilize,
and and get back to balanced.
Um, and you're right. There are lots of
incredible things happening, not just at
Bedichek, but all across our school
system. And I and I get really
frustrated because it is so negative
right now because of what we're talking
about. But, it's not There There There
are great great schools. And And
sometimes, you know, these ratings are
there because of something that's
outside of the the students' control or
a staff's control.
And it takes time, and there's movement.
You know, we had How many schools do we
have that were 59s? We had like nine,
and then three more that are 58s. I
mean, and the growth that we saw from
just 2 years ago, it's incredible.
And I see it. We see it. That's why
we're coming and asking you. I had you
in a room. Like, what are you doing? How
do we like replicate that? But, at the
end of the day, the state sees it a
certain way. And that's what makes this
painful. And I'm really frustrated that
we're here right now, but I know that if
we don't do something, like, there the
students, you know, long-term trajectory
in Austin ISD and those coming after
them could be adversely impacted because
we lose local control. And it will
happen. Like, if we do not make hard
decisions, it could happen. It happened
like that in Fort Worth.
So, just, um, I love our teachers. I
love our staff. I love our families. I
don't want anybody to go. We have We're
here because of many indecisions over
the last
two or three decades, I would say. Um,
and I hate that I'm the person who has
to do it. Uh, but I I love this school
district, and I I just something has to
change, um, if we're going to protect
who we are.
Uh, and I want to do it in an ethical,
thoughtful way, like, making sure we
protect our staff, making sure that we
listen to We have student voice in the
process.
Um, but it is so hard. And thank you for
bringing that up because it it true.
Like, there are incredible things
happening and there are incredible
things happening here.
Mhm.
>> I coach volleyball and track.
>> I coach volleyball.
>> So, we're going to
So, miss
I'm going to go ahead and we have three
people I know in queue that would like
to ask their questions. So, I'm going to
go that way, but
>> I know that question. I want to answer
that question, but I'll answer it later.
>> We'll come We'll come back to it.
>> Okay.
>> Hi, my name is Selena Castaneda. I
actually have um six daughters all
enrolled in AISD. Six daughters. Uh
we've got Leisure, Crocket, and um three
of my daughters have been enrolled here
at Vidor High. Um
to feed off of what Coach Mendoza was
saying, there is a lot of positive here
at Vidor High. My oldest daughter um she
finished
eighth grade in the
I want to say she was number one, but
she was in the top percent uh top 10
students, not percent. Top 10 students
uh with the highest GPA. She represented
the choir all three years that she was
here. She represented the um
orchestra. And for choir, let me just
mention she went to region and uh all
city. Um both opportunities given to her
because Miss Tannert was here and built
that choir program up. Um orchestra
built by Miss Stewart who took time out
of her summer to train these students
and get them ready for this school year.
Um she also represented the volleyball
team, the basketball team, the track
team
in JHS and
um like I said, finished eighth grade in
the top percent
um with the highest GPA. She maintained
straight A's all 3 years that she was
here, all a part of the advanced
academic program. She would not have had
those opportunities had it not been for
the program that only Bedichek offers.
And by
I know you said that you might you know
you there's plans to move that program
over but um I'll get to that in a little
bit.
Um let me also say that those
opportunities for her would not have
been possible without teachers like Ms.
Ramos, Mr. Nunam, Mr. Jackson,
um Ms. Tanner, Ms. Stewart. Um I want to
make sure I don't forget any of the
teachers that we've had here, Coach
Parker who
she has not stopped coaching and giving
100% to those athletes that she has this
year. There's so much uncertainty and
these teachers and these coaches are
giving 100% to the students still. Um
also Ms. Menhaden, Ms. Bryant,
um
staff like Ms. Atkinson, Ms. Hartman,
Ms. Staman, Ms. Smith. Last year my
daughter didn't have
you know there was so much with her
schedule but she still wanted to be a
part of her orchestra and her choir and
get her Spanish credits. And Ms. Hartman
and Ms.
Atkinson made that possible for her. And
that is what Bedichek is. They give
these these kids opportunity. By taking
Bedichek away you're taking away their
opportunities. She's now at Crockett
striving as a freshman. She's
uh in an upper class math class and in
her class the only other freshman in her
class are from Bette Check.
The only other freshman
in Crockett's upper math classes
are from Bette Check because no other
schools are giving that opportunity to
these kids and she's thriving in that.
She finished the nine weeks making 100s
in all of her classes.
Straight A's in all of her classes again
and that is from the structure that
Bette Check gave her here at Bette
Check. And yes, um
the sports we have
she had those opportunities to learn the
sports and play the sports and get her
straight A's because of
the size of Bette Check. I know that
it's not as big of a school as Covington
or Paredes, but because of the size of
the school she had those opportunities.
And now like I said, she's also in the
choir class over there and she is the
only she's a freshman
and she is the only student in that
class who knows how to read music and
that is because of Miss Tanner and Miss
Stewart here and their programs that
they built here at Bette Check. Um
sorry, I know this is long. I also have
an eighth grader here on the same path
who represents the students she's a
student rep for CAC. She's a
um she will not be happy if I get this
wrong. She is the president of NJHS and
she is the
uh also a part of the student council as
um the secretary. She represents the
volleyball, the basketball and the track
team all while still maintaining
straight A's all three years in the
advanced academic program. Um
and she will be finishing like her
sister with those two high school math
credits. She's got a bunch of elective
high school credits. She's got the IPC
credit, which I heard was also going to
be taken away from the program, which
it's an amazing opportunity for them to
have that because they're able to go
into Crockett and take those ACC courses
and not have to worry about um their
schedule and scheduling conflicts. Um
Yes.
Yes. Um
The other thing I have a sixth grader
here. What are we going to do with her?
She's in the same program. How long is
it going to take y'all to get that
program up and running?
Um and then the other the last thing was
just the
um
the location. Bedichek is in one of the
best locations. Um no matter what
direction you're coming from and me
having six kids, I come from every
direction possible. I can get here in a
timely manner. My kids are on time every
day.
Um they have perfect attendance because
this school works for us. So, that's um
I thank you for your time.
Uh and I ask that you take all of that
into consideration and um
maybe rethink
closing down Bedichek for us.
Thank you.
>> We've got other folks in line. Yeah, but
we'll come back to you.
Did you want to just reiterate anything
with that?
>> I mean I first off I'm super impressed.
Um that's that's very it's it's very
impressive. Um I have two daughters.
Uh six I couldn't imagine having six. Um
I love them to death.
Uh you know, I I think what your
students are experiencing is exactly
what we want in Austin ISD. You know,
and and I
I would say that um it's a really
difficult spot that we're in as a school
district. It just is.
Uh there aren't lots of
I would think decisions that we can make
that really bring down the pressure and
stress and risk in the system. There
just aren't.
You know, the the budget, the change at
the federal federal level, you know, the
challenges we have with accountability,
there aren't lots of options unless the
only option is to kind of wait and see
what happens. And I I'm not going to be
the superintendent that introduces a
risk that takes Austin ISD away from our
community. Um
so the way that I kind of process this
is say, "Okay, well,
if I
acknowledge that that is something has
to happen, my focus needs to go into how
I support our students."
Right? Programs
when programs fail, it's because they
weren't built out thoughtfully. You
didn't hire thoughtfully.
Um or you started something without
really understanding kind of the
resources required to ensure that it's
sustainable.
And so, for me, that's where the focus
is. I don't have lots of options unless
I close another middle school. I mean,
really, at the end of the day, that's
the only way to to do this. But from a
geography perspective,
you know, there just are different parts
of the city that make it kind of harder
to actually accomplish and almost
impossible in some cases.
So, um I appreciate your comments, and
you know, that that is part of what
we're trying to do as we move forward is
figure out like how to do this
thoughtfully, um and transition as best
we can cuz we want your daughters to
have get everything they have out of
Bedichek, which I know is not possible,
um but we learn and we adjust and we
improve and then support the entire city
as you move forward.
>> All right, I'm going to go to this
parent here cuz they've been waiting a
while and then another student.
>> My name is Sylvia Peña.
I'm here because
if y'all knew the ratings that the kids
were already failing,
why didn't you
offer summer school for them? If you
didn't offer summer school for them,
that's why we're in this situation of
you looking at us closing our schools.
We have a lot of support. We have a lot
of
real good academic classes, and
if it wasn't for
Mrs. Atkins and the tutoring and the
ROTC, none of other schools have ROTC
for the kids. And my son needed the
discipline, so being in there in the
ROTC did help him
>> Yeah.
>> to be a better person. But there's a lot
of opportunities that was here for the
kids. But why didn't y'all do it?
Why didn't y'all go and say, "Hey, y'all
already failed. Why didn't y'all make an
effort for the kids to come to summer
school like y'all did some of the other
schools?" From what I hear was that
there was three schools that were
offered summer school. We would not be
in this position
if y'all didn't offer it to us. Y'all
say y'all care about the students and
the students come and their attendance
is real good here at Better Chance.
>> Yeah.
>> It's all about the money, not about the
kids. And that's not right.
Be honest.
>> Oh, I'm I'm sorry.
>> it was about the kids being in the
school seats, but yet you're not
offering them the summer school that
they need.
>> So, so just to be clear, when you think
back about the last couple years,
we're talking about 22-23, 23-24, and
24-25 that drove like kind of the
pressure here.
Right? So, I think about um
what instability looks like in a system.
Right, wrong, or indifferent. You know,
there there were there were things that
happened out of the pandemic, leadership
changes that occurred that created
instability across AISD, period.
As you move forward, you know, I would I
am committed. I've continued to be
committed to provide the supports as our
students need.
But here's the other thing is is I
have to understand what does each school
community need, allocate the resources,
and then move forward, and move
outcomes. The one thing I don't want to
do, and this is something that is a
challenge is you could make different
decisions
and you could probably move outcomes in
a way that would get you to
you know, be a
you know, to meet accountability, but
you're going to do it in a way that
perhaps like introduces harm into the
school system, right? You can do things
in a different way. What we're electing
to do is to do it in a sustained way so
that if I'm here, Principal Atkinson is
here, and whoever is here in the next
many many years the system as a whole is
still thriving. Right now, if we just
react and then, you know
teach to the test.
>> school for many years.
>> I It has been a strong school.
>> Mrs., I just want to say something, too,
because I hear this a lot that it's
about money, it's about money.
It's not like when we Right, but where
does that money go, right? Right, you
ask why we don't have summer school. The
three schools that got summer school, we
had to We literally had to dip into our
fund balance because we didn't We don't
have enough money to do it. We had to
literally borrow from our savings to do
it. Our savings is dwindling, right? And
so, what this When we say it's about the
money, it is about spending our money
where it will benefit students cuz right
now with so many empty seats across the
district we'll go We fix the HVAC on the
same school three times in 1 year.
That's money down the drain, right? It's
not money that's going to pay for summer
school. And so, that is why we're going
through this process, and the amount of
money that this this process frees up
more than half of it is going back into
our school so that we can provide the
level of service. So, I know you're
hearing it's about money, but it's not
like the district just pockets that
money cuz we want to have money. We want
to free up the money so that we can put
it in the schools, okay?
>> When it comes to education, some of the
parents doesn't have a problem paying
for the kids' education for their
schooling, for their church, for
tutoring anything that the kids would
need to make them succeed in their
academics.
>> Yeah, and and I think um
we as a superintendent need to figure
out
we need to be honest about the fact that
not every student has the same need.
Right? Some students need more and
that's okay. And we we acknowledge that.
And we actually believe that is the
right way to operate. Right? Students
who've historically been underserved
just need more resources to to be
supported. And and we
have made our systems responsive to
that. You know, we have different lists
that we use when it comes to hiring,
when it comes to placement. There are
decisions that other superintendents in
other districts probably would have made
regarding, you know, how many assistant
principals would you have on a campus
that is a certain size? Or how many um
instructional coaches? Or how many um
you know, teachers would you have in a
grade level if you get down to 140 or
150 kids? Well, the math would say you
need to go down to one and a TA, but we
say no, it's going to be two. So, we
have we have spent a lot of energy
trying to figure out what is the the the
the bottom that we will not let any
school go below, right? Because that's
going to harm our students who've been
historically underserved.
What I'll tell you is the agent of
change in a school district is teachers.
Right? And we have our teachers cannot
afford to live here in Austin anymore.
We have about a third of them that live
outside the city.
And so, if we're going to compensate
them, if we're going to provide the
resources,
we have to find
money to do it.
And right now we are just so
inefficient. And it's it's not that
anyone school was identified because of
what they've done. We have incredible
schools doing incredible things. It's
really a function of the whole in trying
to find the seats to pull out so they
become more efficient so that the
dollars that we have can go to teachers,
can go to programming, can go to the
summer school. Because right now, you're
right. I don't have the the or the funds
to do it all. I just don't.
>> It's going to get worse because you're
going to send all these kids to the
different schools and the classes are
going to be overcrowded.
>> They They They won't
>> looked into that already?
>> Yeah, staffing plans, we the num- the
size of the school, um the
student-teacher ratio, all of those
things we've evaluated. And that We
would have never offered something that
we think We don't think we could have
been able to execute.
>> So, just to clarify, the
student-to-teacher ratio doesn't change
when you consolidate schools. There's
still the same allocations. And in fact,
the campuses with the turnaround plans
are going to have extra funds. So, if
they choose they want to have an extra
teacher to lower it even more, they can
do that. Um I'm going to go ahead cuz
we've had the student patiently waiting
for a while, and I think there were a
couple of other parents that had their
hands up.
>> One more. What about transportation for
them?
How's that going to work?
>> Uh so, our policy right now is uh if
you're going to Covington or if you're
going to Paredes,
um if you're outside 2 miles, you you
will have transportation from Austin
ISD. Or if you're on the other side of a
hazardous intersection, like, you know,
you That might be like a William Cannon
and like Westgate or some some larger
kind of intersection. That's our policy.
So, the way that it works now, given
where we are in proximity to Covington
and Paredes, uh the vast majority of
students are going to have it. If there
are any gaps, you know, I need to make
sure I understand where those are, but
transportation will be provided uh if
you're outside the 2-mile radius or if
there is a hazardous intersection. And
when you get to middle schools and high
schools as big as they are and as how
big the footprint is, you see that quite
a bit. So, transportation will be
provided.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay, let's go right here to the
student.
>> Is it Isabella? What was it?
>> Rosabella.
>> Rosabella. Ah, sorry.
>> You said you had wanted to give students
what they need, but our students need
better check.
>> Yeah, I I
>> Will you
>> I heard you. I This is very, very hard.
Um I want to make sure our students
see themselves in Austin ISD, and this
is why this conversation is important.
So, I understand what you need, what our
families need. Um, it doesn't keep us
from making a hard decision,
necessarily,
uh, but it does help us understand how
to support you through it. So, thank
you. I'm sorry.
>> Okay, I think we have time for about two
more questions. Or, I'll go three more
cuz I know the three of you have been
waiting. Okay.
>> Hi there. I'm
Dylan Vickner. I have a
eighth grader who attends Bedichek, uh,
fourth grader who is very much looking
forward to attending Bedichek in a
couple years.
Um,
I guess real quick, obviously, closing
schools can lead to crowded classrooms,
which is not really conducive to the
learning process. But, my main question
is, um,
considering that in the last year, uh,
Austin taxpayers have paid nearly $700
million
towards the Robin Hood recapture plan to
fund other school districts districts,
uh, throughout the state of Texas.
Um,
and simultaneously, the state has a $24
billion tax surplus.
How How is it not possible to reallocate
some of those funds to help, you know,
cover this $20 million deficit?
>> Yeah.
What's your name?
>> Dylan.
So, Dylan, um, what you're describing is
what the board and I have been fighting
for for the last many years. I mean,
like we we have.
So, the the Robin Hood or the, um,
recapture, we spent we sent $714 million
about 8 weeks ago, and then we spent $56
million
about 2 and 1/2 weeks ago.
And you're right. That money is
collected, it goes to the state, the
state redistributes it to school
districts, but not all of it. They
actually keep a good amount of it.
The problem is
we have fought and fought and fought.
And when you are only a couple
legislators here in Central Texas and
then every other legislator throughout
the state of Texas, over 200, 300 of
them collectively between the Senate and
the House,
benefit from recapture because their
school districts are getting something.
They're not going to vote to
have it be different than the way it
already is.
Like that's the honest truth. That's how
you get things to the state. You have to
have a majority, right, in the Senate
and the House and then it has to get
passed. And so I promise you I we have
been fighting and fighting and fighting
for years around this very topic. We've
sued in 2017, uh 2017 there was a
lawsuit. We challenged it in 2019.
Uh this time around we're pushing,
pushing, pushing, but it's not going to
change. It's just not.
Uh now what we So our approach kind of
shifted uh for the 89th Legislature and
we said, "You know what?
Fine.
I get that we're not going to be able to
move it because the powers that be, but
let's just fund public education. Let's
just fund public education better. Let's
just do that.
You know, let's raise the basic student
allotment. Let's figure out how to put
billions of dollars into the school
system and give districts the autonomy,
when appropriate, to spend as they see
fit, right? Because we choose to spend
it on teachers.
Other school districts may choose to
spend it on something different. Uh and
there was some movement in the 20 in the
89th Legislature. The problem with it is
that lots of the dollars were um set
asides for certain programs, right?
Really kind of
you know, um confining how you spend
your dollars.
Uh and at the end of the day, whenever
it all nets out, it ended up being
around a $10 million increase for AISD
bottom line. Now teachers got raises,
which is great, and we believe in
raises. We've done three raises in a
row. Um but that is that is the the
biggest issue that we have. And another
thing I would say exacerbates this is
the federal government. The disruption
of the federal government. Y'all think
that we're the state is not the only one
that funds us, right? Title 1, Title 2,
Title 3, and Title 4 dollars all come
from federal government. Earlier this
year I sent a letter to our all of our
families saying two, three, and four um
grants or title dollars were frozen. I
had to get 100 people in a room and tell
them that the source of funding used to
pay their salary is frozen.
And I'm not in a position because I
don't have the resources because of all
these things we just described to
carry them.
Right? Without really impacting our fund
balance. And so we had hard
conversation. These individuals support
multilingual education. These people
support like all the things that we
believe in.
And the reality is that I am trying to
desperately move us to a place where we
don't have to rely on funding sources
funding sources that are variable, that
change like that. And that's why this
work is so important, but very very
difficult. So I'm going to continue to
fight, but I want you to know why our
strategy has changed. It's because
unfortunately Austin in front of
anything makes it to where almost
everybody's going to not vote for it.
>> And I'll just add with this last
legislative session, there were
estimates that in order to get our
funding up to keep up with inflation
that we needed to get an extra 1,100 to
1,300 per student. And what ended up
coming was about came out to about 200
per student. So that's how And the
legislature wanted to celebrate. It was
a big bill and it was a lot of money to
schools, but it was nowhere near what it
would cost just to keep up with the
rising costs.
>> I'll be quick.
My name is Maria. Um I am a transfer
parent since I don't know, seven years
now. I had a previous student who is now
in college.
Um
you know, my also have a daughter who is
in seventh grade. She was really upset
whenever I did tell her it's time to
move out. I'm actually moving out from
Austin.
And I think as a parent I'm not even
have a question. I'm I'm going to give
you
an opinion.
Mr. Segura, you have it really hard. The
funding issue is being
around you know, our
for I don't know for the longest I
remember for 18 years cuz I also have a
older daughter
who is 25.
And you have it really hard. What I see
this is a district monopoly game
where you have to finish it.
So best of luck.
Um I think that putting the kids
combining the kids with two schools in
one school is a bad bad bad bad idea.
I It's happening right now because we
also have to close Lanfer
to Palm. Palm is also getting closed,
you know.
Um my kid he has to wake up at 6:00 at
6:00 a.m. because that he have to get
picked up by a bus at 6:40.
You know, parents are not allowed to
drop off our kids from Lanfer to Palm
due to the traffic for the Palm parents.
Um they're not even allowed to play in
the playground. The big playground is
not for Lanfer. So we have to build a
little playground for our our kids to
play.
Yes.
Yeah. So it's really hard that they
can't go to their gym. They had to build
a mobile, you know, place for them to
play. That's where they do gym classes.
And you know, I've been dealing with it,
you know, since we have to do it and I'm
like, "Okay, well it's a transition.
They're rebuilding Lanfer. I live within
2 minutes walking from Lanfer."
You know.
I'm a transfer parent like I said for 7
years I've been driving my daughter it
don't matter like she said she is
leading she's
an Austin student.
Um I don't know
she's in everything.
Um so yes, she's already crying about it
and
what's your going What's going to happen
what what I think cuz a parent we're not
looking at Austin ISD district as an
option now. Charter school maybe, you
know, but to me is move out of Boston.
Um
my opinion is
I have no idea what you're going to do.
But it's not an option, I guess uh
combining the kids to school in one
because I think like she said, the
programs is not the same.
You get to pick what you have already in
your home. You're the visitor, so you're
going to deal with whatever I guess the
district the district's going to go with
it, you know?
So, I'm sorry, but that's an issue.
>> Can you speak a little bit to when we
bring two communities together? I think
that's an important point you made that
we don't want anyone to feel like a
visitor that it's going to be a uniting
the two schools.
>> Uh yes, thank you, Ally. So, um
I I appreciate that. It is hard. Um
This is hard. I don't You know, we've
been around for 144 years.
Uh this still school district has
evolved, has changed. There are things
that are
in our bones that are probably not great
things.
Right? And unless we change and do
something pretty significant, um we will
not
continue to be the district that I think
we all collectively want. Because there
are families in other parts of town
that don't have the resources, don't and
I don't have the resources to deploy to
ensure that their students and that they
have a strong thriving neighborhood
school.
And so, it's it's very complex and I
have to think about 70,000 students
um and 116 schools, not just one and one
and one and one, right? And that's what
makes this really, really hard cuz these
are our students, these are our
families, these are our neighborhoods.
Like I grew up here. I love this city. I
love this school district.
Um when it comes to bringing families
together or schools together, uh we have
um teams that we've that we're building
called bridge teams.
And we've done this in the past uh when
we went through the closures in 2019 or
modernized campuses where we bring
schools together,
uh Norman Sims or Metz and Sanchez,
where we are very proactive. We lay it
out, we talk about, you know, who needs
to be at the table, you know, how are we
going to honor the history of the um
school that is consolidating, you know,
how do we get the PTAs together, what do
programs look like? I mean, all the
supports, right? And so,
um that is what's going to happen in
this case. Uh and so, those we have the
frameworks for the teams. They're going
to be led. I'm going to track KPIs, um
different uh
data points that I'm going to use to
ensure that everything's being done uh
with fidelity. Uh so, if there's
something that gets hung up, I can, you
know, address it immediately.
And so, that's how we have to do it. Um
we can be successful. I don't want you
to leave Austin ISD. I'm sad to hear you
say that, especially if at least one of
your kids isn't going to probably
Langford next year cuz they'll be a
fifth grader when Langford opens in
26-27. So, that would be pretty awesome.
Um
Uh and also, thank you for sharing me
the information around Palm and
Langford. I had not understood that uh
as being a a
limiting kind of opportunity for
students uh in that playground.
Um
Yeah.
>> Okay, this is going to be our last
question.
>> Hello, my name is Stephanie. Um I have a
child in sped and in scores.
Um my question is why advocate and have
this get-together to express our
feelings and concerns if the I feel the
decision is already being made without
taking in consideration
our students and parents. Why not count
on us before all this? I understand the
rules and regulations.
But, that's my question.
>> Yeah.
So, um
we didn't know So, we started this
process in February and March of of this
year, right? Um we we identified the the
five big things we're trying to tackle.
Um through the process, accountability
23, 24, and 25 came out, and then in
August it set the timeline for when we
have to respond. So, we were going
through our process, which which you
know, would have been different if we
didn't have those milestones, as you
mentioned, that we had to hit here in
November.
Um you know, we produced a plan.
Uh we go through a process to refine and
improve the plan,
but there aren't lots of um
kind of big pieces that can move based
on the goals that were identified early
in the process with our board and the
administration.
Right? We talked about what those were.
Um if you don't want to align feeder
patterns,
then fine, but that's that that's
something that we agreed to. If we don't
If we I'm going to be really clear about
this, like we have to reduce our budget
deficit. We have to.
Um and if we don't reduce the number of
seats, then we'll never get there.
So, if we begin to take schools off,
then you're going to be right back here
in two or three years, if even not
sooner, like having the exact same
conversation, but this time there'll be
more urgency around it.
Uh it'll be like
you know, zero time to plan, because the
district will be on the verge of like
insolvency, essentially. And that is
another reason the state can take over a
school district. It happens all the time
Doesn't happen all the time, but it
happens enough. Those are the two big
reasons, right? Accountability and then
finances.
Um I don't want to delay a hard vote um
for the sake of delay. We've done that.
We've done that over and over and over
again in our history of Austin ISD.
I'm not going to do it. I would rather
be really clear as to what we're
tackling together, believe that we as a
school district and as our community
want the best for all of our students,
move forward, and acknowledge that
there's going to be disruption, but if
we plan and we love our kids and we do
this as a community, we can get there.
Um so so that's why we're approaching it
this way. Uh yes, I'm taking feedback.
Um I'm not the one that ultimately will
vote. The board votes. Um, but I will
tell you that we didn't arrive at this
plan or this element in the plan just,
you know, without like a lot of thought.
And I think you see that in the plan
because of how interwoven it is. There
are there are lots of things that we
considered.
>> Did you have a follow-up?
>> Yes, ma'am.
>> If you don't
like you're saying this is based on five
big
categories and then if you don't meet
it, is the state going to still grade
you the same way and then are you going
to be still looking at possible a state
takeover?
>> So, um, this is our this is the five
areas that I talked about, right?
Transfer policies, accountability, um,
inefficiencies, programmatic moves, and
feeder and feeder pattern alignment.
Like those things are our goals to move
the entire system. I will tell you I
don't know that we would ever ever be
able to align feeder patterns in East
Austin unless we were taking taking
taking on all this work together. Right?
Like so so you think about some schools
like Covington goes almost wholly into
into Crockett.
Right? We have middle schools in East
Austin that go into four and five high
schools, right? And I I think I said
that earlier.
You never would we as a school district
probably wouldn't be able to take that
on and align the feeder patterns unless
we were taking it all together. If that
makes any sense. So, um, if we don't
meet our objectives in the plan, will
the state take us over? I mean, no. No,
they won't.
But what I'll say is
my job is to ensure that that as we move
forward we're always moving in the right
direction. I would say if we the further
we get away from hitting our goals in
the plan, the more risk that is
introduced from the state regarding
whether they take an intervention or
not. Or the more risk that we'll have to
manage regarding budget in, you know, 24
months or 48 months. What I don't want
to
be is is a school district that all of a
sudden has all these things, you know,
facing it. And what the state will do is
come and say, "Okay, we're going to do
this. These teachers are out. These
schools are closing. No communication.
No engagement. It's done." That's That's
how it happens. Because they have to
take that type of corrective action
because they're saying, "You should have
done it before. Why didn't you make a
hard decision, Matias? I'm going to make
it for you."
And and my my hope is that because we're
doing it, it'll be more thoughtful. I
know it's going to be painful, um but
it's done by people who love the school
district and love your students, not by
the state of Texas. And so we're kind of
wanting to
Like I I would argue that other school
districts are being taken over that wish
they would have made decisions years
before they got to that point. And And
that what I'm doing is saying, "We're
not going to get there."
Is that helpful?
>> No.
>> Okay.
So, that's all the questions we have
time for. I think there are some of us
that might be might be able to stick
around a little bit longer for
one-on-one conversations if needed, but
some of us do need to get on our way. Um
I'm just going to go over the timeline.
So, we're in phase three of the process.
Um you heard our superintendent talk
about it beginning back in April. Um but
just some important dates coming up. Um
we have the November 6th board meeting
is where there's going to be the next
conversation about the draft plans that
we've presented. Um so, these
conversations that we're having in the
community. Um there's also a new um
comment card that was emailed to y'all
and I believe texted on Friday. So, make
sure that's the new um card. If you go
to the old one, it's actually going to
redirect you to the new one, but we are
still collecting feedback. But there
will be a conversation um on November
6th. Is that this Wow, that is this
Thursday, right? This Thursday. Um and
then the the board is anticipated to
vote on the final plan November 20th. Um
so, thank you so much everyone. This is
a really great conversation. Oh, thank
you to our students who left so quietly.
Um and we again, some of us can stick
around if we didn't get to all of your
questions. So, thank you so much
everyone.